hello everyone my name is marcus  brownlee and today  today i'm going to be telling you why i  love windows 7.  a lot of people have windows 7 and a lot  of people love it and there are plenty  of reasons why  speed stability and pure awesomeness  under speed well windows 7 is a little  different windows 7 is blazingly fast as  you guys know i make a lot of techie  videos on my channel and windows 7 would  make editing incredibly powerful  and then there's superb stability what  more can i say  it's consistency just works  and under awesomeness yeah i'm sure  you've watched a couple computer tv  reviews or seen an amazing gadget setup  that's kind of like windows 7. it's just  plain awesome  jump lists arrow snap customization  features smooth animations pure power  arrow on steroids  just awesome  well that's why i love windows 7 tell me  why you love windows 7 down in the  comments section below  until next time mkbhd signing out  peace